What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today, we're playing a penhold tournament
Let's see who wins!
So the penhold grip is the traditional Chinese
table tennis grip
So you basically hold the racket like a pen
First match, me versus Emil
Let's go!
To be honest I think I'm gonna lose this one
Well, I think so too so...
Good luck!
I think I should have
moved a bit better but
I don't want to
This is going pretty well
I remember I have said that before too
and then I lost all the points after that
I'm giving you a head start
Still giving a head start
Still?
Still
I have to give him one point
Thanks
I tried like a side spin
I don't know
You don't know what you tried
No...
Now you started playing, did you Otto?
Yeah I had to
Wow, nice forehand Emil
Thank you
The chop block didn't quite work there
I won't miss those anymore
No, what am I doing?
I came too close and I wasn't like
should I take the backhand or forehand
That was good
Thanks
What?
That wasn't supposed to go in!
No it wasn't
Zero zero
I tried to set you up for a little
Counter smash
My serves are exactly the same as normal
That's true
I hit it with the finger
Wait, new!
"Thanks"
Oh sorry
That was too difficult
I was just trying to hurt Emil there
Clearly
I expected you to go around the net
A bit stiff
Wow! That was good
Safe shots
This much
I was a bit trapped in here
Luckily it didn't come on the table
I'm not sure what I was waiting there
Thanks
You have a backhand
I'm really sorry
That's the only way you're gonna win this match
More of those
I need only ten more
You haven't seen my
good serve yet
Bring it
Okay, that serve is okay
I'm sorry
I shouldn't laugh
You're laughing now but
9-9 when i rip that backhand on
then we see who's laughing
Yeah you can always dream!
It's good to have dreams in your life
He is going for the backhand
You see that is top spin, Otto
Oh he's serious!
He's serious, look at him jumping!
Come on
5-3
That was like the screamer guy
Good rally though boys
Ok I need to calm down a bit
I've never seen Otto this excited
Me neither
I have to give it to you that was a good shot
I should have just kept pushing like Otto did
I said I was gonna calm down
That means pushing
Oh I'm so sorry Otto
Had to go for it
Sorry!
There is as much in stake in this match as
the
500k
subscribers
No i think this is more!
This is even more
I missed it
it would have been so perfect
I could have just seen you miss the
backhand receive
I would have gone around the net
Backhand serve
Wait
Well look at that!
Match point!
Match point
Sensei is going to lose this one
9-10
Yes!
It happened!
The Sensei is beaten
As I said
I'm gonna lose that one
never even had a chance
How does it feel to be beaten Otto?
Yeah good
You know
Nice change
Being always on top
It's hard mentally
yeah yeah
mentally so it's good to lose sometimes
to keep your life balanced
Yeah
Keeps you on the ground I would say
So that you're not too good
Yeah, exactly
And also this relieves some pressure
so you don't have to
keep on winning everything
I don't have to win all the time so
I think it's really good
Let us know which tournament you want to see next
And don't forget to hit subscribe
And watch our previous episodes there
Until next time!